you also wrote a you co-authored a book
smart money smart kids and I have a five
year old what should I be teaching my
five-year-old right now about money and
then how do i how do i because how do i
I made a lot of mistakes in my 20s with
money how do I prevent her from making
some of those same mistakes well just
say a little word of encouragement to
that end point because I think a lot of
people and I have two kids of my own
there's still three and one so they're
they're younger but I look at them and
mistakes I've made you know whether it's
with money or other things and I'm like
you know I want them to learn those
lessons but I so don't want them to have
to go through that pain and so I really
believe you know in my family's story my
parents filed bankruptcy the year I was
born and so I look at that I'm like
that's the worst of the worst right
you're at the bottom of the bottom and I
don't believe I have to do that to live
out good principles with money you know
just gonna go out and file for
bankruptcy
so I'll have to say yeah your dock your
kids do not have to make the mistakes
that you've made I don't believe that so
a five-year-old I mean tactically
speaking you don't have to make it
complicated some people like you know
I've been showing her what a SEP IRA is
the difference between a Rob well Dave
Ramsey's my dad and so people are soon
growing up with Dave Ramsey as my dad is
that we had like mutual funds parties
right budget camps all the time and so
yeah you don't have to do that by any
means so for a five-year-old I mean
simple I always tell parents to teach
them where money comes from and money
comes from work and so for us growing up
we were never given an allowance we were
always on commission so you work you get
paid you don't work you don't get paid I
love that and it's good because you meet
like 35 year olds who don't know that
right I mean so yeah it's a good lesson
to learn at five so teaching them where
money comes from and then doing three
things with money and even getting three
envelopes and you market give save and
spends and once they earn that money you
do it in that order and whatever
percentage you want you know I'm not
that legalistic so you can just do
whatever percentage that you decide to
as parents but you give something first
you save something second and you can
spend less so you're building really all
three of those money muscles and I
adults if you think about it you know
whether it's investing or whatever
you're doing those are really the three
things you can do with money give save
and spend and so starting that early is
huge because I meet people who can save
and spend like no one else but they're
not givers they live their life like
this or you meet people that that give
everything and spend everything in their
broke you can't afford food right and so
ya see balancing out all three of those
things and a five role they can grasp it
and that's the encouraging thing they
can get it so I love how you all
encouraged to give like that is the
number one thing that you always list
because when you know what when I think
of some of the other programs or things
especially growing up I feel like in the
90s was like that prime time for the
infomercial I will make you it's like
right exactly and and and no one ever
talks about that and you know ultimately
that's what Josh and I that's what we
want to help other people do it is I
mean it truly is our our mission it's
funny people all the times like Ryan
wears this minimalist thing going and
you know I mean really I don't know
where it's going but I'll tell you what
I wanted to go know you know ultimately
we all we all need some security we need
to feel some safety for ourselves before
we feel like we can start giving to
other people absolutely and I think
minimalism is a is a nice tool that
helps us to get to that place where we
we can feel like we have enough we can
be content we can be satisfied and once
we have that feeling then we can start
looking outwardly to our friends family
community in contribution so thank you
so much for for sharing that and making
put in putting that first absolutely
because it's I mean it really is the key
to yeah I mean and and I'm and I'm
pretty hardcore on and so are we like we
talked about when you're doing your
budget that the very first line item is
giving and and I talked to almost eight
out of ten people will say oh my gosh
that's so great Rachel but you know if I
don't do that I'm not able to pay X & Y
Z because a lot of people are tight with
their budget but I'm like okay but
you're giving Comcast 100 bucks a month
like you not I mean like it's it's like
where are your priorities and you really
have to think about that it's not always
a math issue it's a heart issue and I
love john d rockefeller his quote is one
of my favorites he said it I never would
have been able to tithe which is give
10% I never
have been able to tie the first million
dollars I ever made if I didn't tithe my
first salary which is a dollar and fifty
a week and people think all the time if
I just had more money I would give but
I'm telling you if it does not become a
habit in your life it gets harder the
more money you get it absolutely does I
remember being back in the corporate
world that's sort of the apex of what I
earned in the corporate world I was
managing 150 retail stores and a couple
hundred thousand dollars a year but I
was giving functionally nothing and and
it was because I was out spending
everything that I made I made good money
but spent even better money so I just
didn't have it to give because I hey I
didn't budget accordingly but but B I
just felt like I'll get to it one day if
I'm making 200 thousand now I can
definitely give someday if I make 400
thousand that's with the magic number
that you can give but of course when I
walked away from the corporate world I
made about about 90 percent less of my
first year I made $23,000 and I gave
more that year than I did when I made a
90 percent more than that and it's
because I made it a priority to do so
and it's still priority for us now and
then also to encourage other people to
give as well because when you compound
that giving I see that you know that's
when you can really change communities
when you can change people's lives
you